hello everyone welcome to another Google
Plus hangout I'm really excited to be
here today to talk about how to get
started with content marketing and I'm
super excited to be joined by Monica
Montesa she works at a Weber Aweber is
the email communication software that I
use to run my business I've used it for
over 10 years and I love it
and she does a lot of the content
marketing creation at a weber and agreed
to spend some of her time today to help
share some of her insights and so
welcome aboard Monica hi thank you it's
great to be here I'm excited to talk
about content with everybody awesome so
you guys know the rules there's a little
chat box there on the right side if you
have a question leave it in there and we
will do our best to get through them in
this conversation but I wanted to start
off quickly Monica just as an
introduction for people why is it
important to create content we deal with
entrepreneurs we've got a million thing
to do where everything from the CEO to
the janitor and our businesses a lot of
times you know I have so many things on
my plate why should I care about
creating content so a lot of people and
the big thing about content marketing is
that you know the focus is really on
your customers and with content you it's
a great opportunity to educate your
customers and teach them about your
products or your services how that can
help them in their lives and you can
educate you can give them more
educational information about other
things that relates your niche and your
industry and it's a really good way to
establish trust with people especially
in a world when you know there's so much
competition and you're probably not the
only person who you know is in your your
market space and um with content can
help you stand out and it's a great way
for people to find you on on Google
search and with SEO terms you can really
you know rank well when you're creating
content that addresses those terms and
its really great for just building
relationships with people and it's
important to keep that in mind that at
the end of the day with content the most
important thing it's your customers it's
your blog readers
people who are using your products and
your services
the focus is for them so content is a
really great way to give them to give
them something that something else in
addition to your products yeah I love
the relationship part of that because a
lot of people try to sell too much
people are not likely to come to your
website and just buy the first time so
that's where having a email newsletter
really helps right in the funnel and to
send them valuable information I'm sure
you guys see it all the time with your
newsletters if all you're doing is is
pitching products you probably gonna get
people on subscribing and not being a
part anymore but if you're sharing guide
will information on going they're gonna
want to it's like dating before you get
married right they want to know that you
know what you're talking about
and that you care about them and you're
helping them and I mean I built my whole
business just through content marketing
I'm a huge fans um so for entrepreneurs
who are trying to do this how did it get
started what's my first step to getting
into content marketing so the first
thing is definitely to UM take a look at
who your audience is and understand what
their needs are I know a lot of people
who get started with content marketing
the first step that they do is just come
up with a list of questions that they
frequently hear customers asking me
about and then they start writing
content maybe it's a blog post or maybe
they'll create a YouTube video that
answers those questions and when people
are searching for those questions and
trying to find that information online
hopefully you know they'll come across
your content and that that's how they'll
discover you but really understanding
your audience that's gonna be key to
creating content that's going to
resonate with them and help you really
convey your expertise and you know what
you know and yeah definitely start with
the Eric customers I love it so we've
got a bunch of questions coming in again
for you guys watching live you can ask
on that right side in the chat box first
up is help or desk in a world full of
information and content what are your
favorite ways to stand out from your
competitors so I know for me and the
team here we definitely like to go more
in depth and provide a lot of practical
advice
so if we see that a competitor's you
know talking about a specific topic we
try to take a different angle and we try
to you know also focus on our tone of
writing to help us stand out from the
competition we also like to create
different types of content so you know
not every competitor is going to be
creating the same content in the same
format as you necessarily so we like to
create videos we have a quick tip series
in addition to our blog posts we also
have some how-to articles to help
educate our customers and that's that's
been really helpful too and creating a
variety of content to help keep people
entertained I like this this is a funny
question for me because I don't spend
much time looking at my competition at
all and what they're doing help her desk
so what what I do is I think about what
do I care about what's the message that
I want to get out what is inspiring me
what am i frustrated by what's the
positive impact I want to have on the
world
what's the famous story that I want to
tell and that's what I create content
around really I create content that I
wish somebody else had created so it
created selfishly for me these are the
things that I want to see helping
entrepreneurs and I don't pay much
attention to what my competitors are
doing I think the world is in most
markets big enough that lots of
different content providers can exist so
I wouldn't I guess I just find it being
really you're playing defense if you're
just doing looking at what the
competitors are doing where I prefer to
focus on my strengths or what I'm good
at and nobody can copy me because I'm me
and so nobody can copy you if you're
creating stuff that you really care
deeply about and so maybe that's a bit
of a curveball answer but that's what I
think so that's cool I'm sorry I'm just
gonna say I totally agree with that too
if you're staying true to yourself and
creating content that resonates for your
specific audience because your
competitors might have a slightly
different audience and then than yours
and if you create content for you know
that's always keeping up with your
competitors you might sometimes miss a
mark with what your audience actually
wants so that is a good point I
definitely agree with that too
next up is Andre who wrote a question in
Spanish which I can't understand is
something about Google Translate in
there I don't speak Spanish so sorry
Andre but I'm just curious what are your
thoughts Monica on multilingual content
and how to manage that kind of channel
so it's not just English content but in
different languages as well have you had
to deal with that a weber yeah we have
with that we definitely rely a lot on
our emails to to help send messages out
in different languages that's really
helpful because if you're blogging
you're not necessarily gonna write a
blog in all different languages and it
does help to have you know Google Google
Translate and there's so many great
options for people to you know translate
your content if they need to I know with
our YouTube videos we have an option
where people can read like a transcript
so they can always translate that or
they can use closed captioning so there
are some different options where they
can see it in different languages but it
is that is tricky that's a tricky one
yeah I don't do a lot that's
multilingual mostly because again back
to like the first point that's not me I
don't really speak many languages but
one thing that I have done that's helped
a little bit is I use a website called
Amara its amara.org am a are a org and
what it helps do is allow people to add
translations of your captions on your
YouTube videos so I'll have people from
around the world who are looking at my
videos and they say I love the videos
Evan I wish you could make them with
Japanese subtitles or captions can I
help you somehow
and so Amara is a free tool that they
can use to basically look at any video
and then add their own native language
in the captions so people can watch it
in English but then be able to read it
in their own language and some of the
videos have been translated to like 23
or 25 different languages which is
pretty cool so you can get your
community involved as well to help them
help you translate that content till
cash writing in
hi what do you think is the first step
towards marketing any product or person
it's a good question
um so I think for a lot of people you
know it's easy to think of the end goal
you know we want to get this many people
to buy our products you know we just
want to get our name and message out
there but I think it's important to kind
of take a step back and really consider
how your product or service is going to
help other people out there so one
example that I love is Apple when they
first came out with the iPod their
campaign was all about the concept that
you can have a thousand songs in your
pocket so you don't have to worry about
you know going through all your CD
collection you have all your music with
you everywhere you go and they really
understood that when they were marketing
to their audience and you know they
really captured on that specific need of
people who would want to use their
product and even those who might not
listen to a lot of music because they
maybe had trouble unwrapping the little
plastic on those DD Braun cases and you
know they just made it so easy for
people to get music and have it with
them everywhere they go so their ability
to really understand what needs they
were satisfying with their product was
so key and it helped them you know
really communicate with with the world
about you know the iPod so cool yeah you
know I'm a big believer in core selling
and core marketing and that's so the
first step in that is figuring out what
it is that you staying for what are you
staying for as a human being what's the
positive like you're trying to have in
the world and then use that as your
marketing where a lot of people most
people start off selling the features
you know our software can do this and
then somewhere along the way they figure
out to do benefit selling benefits
marketing well instead of just being
able to send out a thousand emails our
software will help you build a better
relationship with your customers right
so that you start getting to more the
benefits but the the bigger layer on top
of that the next graduation step is to a
course on what are you staying for why
is it important people want to know why
you're doing this business and why you
care before they're gonna pay attention
to you and so
you know - all of a believed right it's
here on the wall everything I do flows
through belief making his webinars for
you guys making the videos that I do
creating the products that I do and so I
would start if I was at the beginning
trying to figure out how to market my
product I would suffer thinking and what
do I stand for as a person as a company
and then how can I create a unique
message that resonates with me that I
think will resonate with my audience as
well
Bernardo writing in what's the best way
to stand out as a graphic designer
for graphic designer well you definitely
have the advantage of having a lot of
visuals on your side so I would
definitely start with you know adding
your portfolio or at least just some
examples of some of your best work to
your website you know definitely
showcase that and you know you can
definitely use content on your side -
just by blogging about some basics of
graphic design that can help you get
discovered on search engines when people
are googling for you know really basic
things like what font should I use on my
website that's not gonna be really
hideous like Comic Sans um no offense
anyone who likes common sense but it's
it's good to start with the basics there
and to you know really show that you're
a thought leader in your space and you
know accompany that with visuals just
keep it basic for your your audience and
then when they're ready for taking their
graphics to the next level they can look
to you for professional help yeah it's a
tough business because there's so many
graphic designers and a lot of people
think oh I'll just get my my nephew to
create something for me or my brother or
my high-school friend it's been so
commoditized that it's hard to stand out
and I think the way to do it is is one
through the content through through
articles or videos or Twitter or
whatever your medium is if you're if
you're better on camera than you are in
writing then I would go YouTube as my
content platform as opposed to writing
if you're a great writer go with the
blog or newsletter I'd also try to see
if if there's some kind of tribute
pieces I could make like what's so
unique about your style the
than everybody else that's the biggest
thing if I put out a job posting for a
graphic designer I'll get thousands of
people applying what is so different
about yours it's gonna make me want to
come to you as the default person right
what do you care about does that scream
through your art and I'd like it doing
some tribute pieces look at I don't know
if you're doing graphic design for if
you doing logos if you're doing websites
brochures but have a fun time playing
around like if you love baseball I'm a
big trial Blue Jays fan we're going to
the playoffs this year finally
redesigned their logo right like put it
in your own put your own spin on it if
you're a logo designer right that could
be content that you release there's
something unique and different that
nobody else is doing and people can get
a flavor for for who you are and the
kind of work that you can do I think it
would challenge people and make people
think next I'm John I'm a magician no
really and one of my problems is my
target market thinks magicians are all
the same what should I do to convince
them that I'm different and worth paying
for so I think that kind of also goes in
along with what Evan was just saying
about you know finding what makes you
different and what makes you unique and
really I'm just expanding on that
concept and that thought with your
content and your marketing I definitely
get some testimonials onto your web page
to kind of show that you know people
find value from your entertainment
services and I think that's you know
it's a great way to show that your
personality and show some of the tricks
that you do as far as content goes you
could even maybe show you know a trick a
week you could do a little magic show
for everybody to kind of just give
people a taste of what you have to offer
and then as well as you know have like
your spin on it so you said that you're
you know you'd like to have a little
humor involved you just make sure that
shows through and that your personality
shows through a lot to to help you stand
out above the rest yeah I really love
that advice to be yourself
because all magicians not all magicians
but a lot of magicians will be kind of
the blocks in version and a lot of
people are the boxing version of
themselves
which is boring and corporate
and people don't really pay attention to
it as much in terms of where to produce
content I think video is your best bet I
think you'd have a lot more success with
a YouTube channel and creating regular
content there because you're in such a
visual medium I think you have a lot
more success with that and maybe people
hit your website and they sign up for
your newsletter you can send them
regular videos of some of your best
tricks or people reacting to what you're
doing anybody who's in that kind of
visual medium if you're a public speaker
if your consultant if you are a graphic
artist who paints things if you are a
street performer all lends itself really
well to creating video content I think
you have a lot more success there than
being on Twitter as an example
yeah and just letting to Monica's point
letting your your content shine through
I think with with all of this it's
important to understand as an
entrepreneur what are you really good at
and working you with love with your
strengths Monica's good at a lot of
things you know you may see her from the
Aweber videos she's also writing for the
blog she does a lot of different things
for you what are you best at you know
are you comfortable in front of the
camera would you rather write blog posts
would you rather write in a newsletter
would you rather create nice graphics
all of that stuff can count as content
to help build relationships with your
clients I wouldn't want you to you know
for those of you watch and go all-in on
YouTube but then hate being in front of
a camera and think YouTube is the only
way to do it there's tons of ways you
can create content for your business to
help you grow but you got to do what is
the most natural and best fitting for
you
David's writing about building a YouTube
channel building subscribers how do we
do it how do we market our YouTube
channel what do you guys do for for
Aweber so any weber one of the pieces of
content we create is a series called
quick tips videos and in those they're
just two to three minute videos where we
talk about email marketing tips and we
take a lot of content inspiration from
our blog so we're repurposing content
that we already have just in a different
format maybe adding some more
information and we share the
videos on YouTube and at the end of
YouTube at the end of the video I'm
sorry we include a link to sign up to
our email list or to also sign up to our
YouTube channel so we try to capture the
interests of the viewers who are
watching our videos and you know try to
keep them coming back for more content
and hopefully eventually you know as
they continue to learn more about email
marketing then when they're ready to
sign up for a provider for example then
you know they'll come to us I love it I
think with YouTube like anything else
that you're trying to learn you suck at
the beginning if you go back to my
channel you watch my first videos I
sucked right it wasn't I wasn't Who I am
now
the content was okay but a lot of people
get on YouTube trying to make it big and
they put out their first videos and they
hate how it looks and nobody reads it no
sorry nobody watches nobody commented
nobody is subscribing to the channel and
you get discouraged where why does
understand it it's a process that if you
keep doing it keep doing more and keep
doing more keep doing you'll get better
right I've done more than 2,000 videos
now so my goal is to get better than I
was the last time and it's not just
jumping from here to here it's taking
little steps forward so one is being
consistent one thing that really helps
me then is to grow it encouraging
communication encouraging engagement in
most of my videos I think in all of my
videos I'll ask people to leave comments
I'll join in the discussion I'll get
involved with you guys we make live
hangouts like this where we can interact
and we can bring in experts like Monica
and we can talk about certain topics
I love Monica's point about getting
people signed up to a newsletter that's
my primary call to action on all of my
videos it's the first link that I have
in my description box is join the
believe newsletter and that leads to a
landing page on my website where people
can sign up and then you get hit with
content ongoing some of that's going to
be part of an autoresponder sequence
which includes some of my videos and
then people come back and watch more the
videos and some of it is broadcasts
where I'm promoting the events like this
say hey join me tomorrow we're going to
do this event
and so you can use that you can use your
newsletters your powerful way to hook
people in to get regular content for
your channel to get people coming back
but in terms of building the channel -
it's like you got to improve the quality
there's so many people doing YouTube and
it's going to come from you getting
better and better and better and better
and better improving yourself how many
subscribers does the Aweber channel have
do you know Monica um I do not know if
it have my head actually hey that's
growing i watch the weekly tips every
week right it's every other week every
other week I watch them I'm always there
common things you guys can check it out
yourself is always related to content
marketing email marketing growing your
business and so that's a cool series one
of the questions from Dominic is do you
remember how you got your first hundred
subscribers on YouTube that's what he's
struggling with at the moment since
social media is flooded with too much
content what do you think getting your
first kind of subscribers for ya for
YouTube he feels there's some
competition lots of people are doing it
social media is flooded he's having a
hard time standing it yeah I think the
idea finding wide life and making sure
that you present your content in a way
that's true to who you are so that you
know everybody's unique and that'll come
through in your content as well and you
can't you just have to get started with
creating the content um like Evan said
it's not gonna be pretty the first few
tries maybe the first 20 tries it might
not be great but at least I'll get into
the habit of you know writing scripts
producing videos getting feedback from
people who are watching your videos and
really taking that into consideration
for how you can make improvements for
next time and it's just gonna it's gonna
be a continual you're going to
continuously improve your videos over
time so you know you have to be patient
as well that is a big part of you know
the content marketing world is your it
takes some time to build your audience
and it takes some time to really get
durable and confident in the content
that you're producing but as you
continue to hear from your viewers and
your audience you know that will help
you validate you know what direction you
should go into and what content you need
to write more about and that'll also
help you get more viewers at the same
time so yeah if you don't have a hundred
subscribers yet and I get that that's
like that's the first big milestone you
get your hundred you get your thousands
and ten thousands of milestones honestly
the harsh truth probably is that your
content just isn't good enough yet and
that's from you just being a beginner
right when you first learn French you're
gonna suck when you first try to ride a
bike you're gonna suck and so I wouldn't
worry about the marketing side of it yet
I wouldn't worry about promoting it on
social too much I wouldn't worry about
trying to do coop and guest
opportunities with other people because
it's probably not gonna help you too
much until you make your content better
until you get better doing it and so I'd
say be consistent with it if you were
serious about this I would say try to
get one video up every day on your
channel just for you to get better for
you to get the practice for you to
improve your skills and be better than
you were the next day and just doing
that and being consistent improving will
get you to your hundred and plus
subscribers and then you can worry more
about the marketing side because if you
market spent all this time marketing
something that isn't very good you're
not gonna get a result and so you got to
make sure you improve the quality of
your productions first money that
applies definitely to you know your blog
as well like if you're writing content
no matter what kind of content you're
producing you definitely want to just
practice and you know be consistent with
it do it on a regular basis so that it
can evolve into something that you're
proud of and you're ready you're ready
to market with so bit of harsh truth but
at least you know what to solve okay
next up laurits would you outsource your
social media marketing what do you think
yeah I mean I definitely think you know
you can pretty much outsource a lot of
things if you really need to I mean
there's so many agencies out there that
create content they do social
and it definitely is helpful though if
you are considering outsourcing your
social is to you know make sure you have
a conversation with whoever's going to
be doing your social and make sure that
they understand your brand what you
stand for who your audience is and
that'll help them and you know be able
to capture your voice your tone how they
should speak to your audience and you
know to make sure that it's it's a
smooth transition and you know it
shouldn't seem like somebody else is
doing the posting for you um it should
all be it should all be fairly smooth
and I think you know having that
conversation will be really important if
that's something you want to pursue yeah
I would recommend one starting to do
some things yourself so you have an
understanding because this is so
important right this could help
transform your business and I wouldn't
just blindly give it off to somebody
else to do I would have an understanding
of it at least even if you don't become
the expert on it just to have an
understanding and be reachable you know
as a CEO of a business you should have a
Twitter account that people can reach
you out and ping you ad that you can
respond from even if it's not your main
company once if you were going to
outsource it I'm not a huge fan of
giving it to another company what I
would do is bring on somebody to work at
my business I would bring on a Monica
right so that you know the founder of
Aweber doesn't have to be out there
creating the content he can hire
somebody super talented like Monica to
come in and create the content and do
these interviews and be on YouTube and
write write the blogs and all of that
stuff that goes along with creating
context but you know she's there she's
at Aweber you know she's got a Jay the
astronaut behind her you know she lives
the culture she gets it
you know they hired her for a reason
that would be my step instead of trying
to go to an agency because I think it's
hard for agencies to really digest your
brand they don't live it and breathe it
like you do and so why I would say you
know you got to try it at least I have a
general understanding of it and then if
you were gonna outsource it I would
bring it to somebody inside the business
either as a part-time role or a
full-time role depending on what you can
afford
but yeah you got to make sure to
Monica's points I think
capture your voice understand what you
stand for can bring that out into every
post because a lot of people are just
dumping coupon codes and hey check out
this article and it's not actually
providing a lot of value because it
doesn't have a lot of meat to it it's
got to have some meat it's gotta have
some heart and that heart comes from you
know ideally you but if not you then
your team because they understand what
it's all about
Sherry's writing in talking about giving
away free things like free chapters or
free books or free content to to get
people I think it's to get people to
sign up for your newsletter I mean I do
that all the time but what what do you
guys recommend it being web in terms of
giving away free content to get people
to sign up yeah we definitely are big
proponents of of offering incentives to
encourage people to sign up you know
we've definitely seen big increases in
our own signup forms when we offer you
know a free pdf guide for example and
that's a really great way to show your
show you share your expertise with
others and kind of give them give them a
taste of what you have to offer before
they even start receiving regular email
content from you you know everybody
loves free stuff and we write about
incentives a lot and we've definitely
heard from a lot of people that you know
they benefit a lot from offering
something in order to get something in
return so you know definitely if you
have something of value like you know
maybe not a full ebook but you could
always combine a couple of blog posts
that you have and you know put something
together in a PDF in a PDF file and
offer it to new subscribers or you can
even offer a checklist or a discount
code and you know free information
people people love it and if they don't
get it from you they might get it from
somebody else so you know offer those
things now and um you know hopefully
people will sign up to your to your list
yeah I'm a big fan of it you'll see a
difference and just do a split test do a
split test between having a join my
newsletter and get this free thing and
you need a way more people who will want
to get that free thing than just call
that action join my newsletter
I think the thing then is one that free
thing has to actually be good right so
you may just show a cover of a PDF but
that PDF actually has to contain some
value because if it doesn't you know you
give it to me and I don't like it then I
gotta unsubscribe from your list and
that first email is super critical so
that email that then sends me the guide
you've hooked me a little bit but now
you have to close the deal right give me
something else talk to me what I'm gonna
be getting tell me that you care tell me
why you're here tell me what I can be
expecting to get because I'm still on
the fence I'm not a die-hard fan yet and
so what you put in your emails you want
to really especially in those first few
ones really make sure you're crafting
them with a lot of heart to give them a
lot of value to make sure that they want
to keep coming back we're gonna I don't
know if you're following the comments
but getting a lot - thank you so much
thank you for the how great answer so
good par love in it that's awesome okay
so Michael how can i leverage content to
increase my search engine optimization
what do you think yeah that's a great
great another great question um so for
SEO um a lot of so a few years ago you
know SEO was a big you know what SEO
first came out everybody wanted to
create content that was filled with all
kinds of search terms and as a result it
kind of diminished the quality of
content that people were producing um
you would find a lot of articles that
were just sometimes dis didn't even make
sense I remember my first marketing job
we had some blog posts that were
questionable because they were written
for you know a search engine they
weren't written for the person who's
actually going to be reading that
content so it's important to kind of
keep that in mind that you know when
you're taking into consideration writing
for SEO you have to remember that it's
it's a balance because the ultimate goal
is to educate your your customers
educate your audience and so it can be
easy to let the SEO take over that but
there are a lot of ways that you can use
SEO to kind of help bolster your posts
as well so for example you know working
at Aweber we want to rank for
email marketing so we often include the
term email marketing in our blog posts
but it's a matter of you know really
understanding like where it's a perp and
making sure that it makes sense and that
you're still providing value to to your
audience yeah the the advice I give is
what advice Google gives basically which
is right for people don't write for the
search engines right for the people and
so you know if I'm typing in email
marketing as a search term and that's
something that you want to get ranked
for then I expect to be given a page it
provides me value about email marketing
so you might come up with a list of 50
different keywords that you're trying to
rank for with each one of those keywords
don't just write something that's 300
words and slap it up and you know you
mentioned that word ten times and you
hope you get it ranked for it that used
to work like way way way all the way
back but not anymore
you want to write for the audiences so
I'm typing that in you know if I'm
typing in salsa classes Toronto I want
to find on that page that I hit relevant
information about salsa classes in
Toronto and it's okay to have a promo
and a call to action and a here's your
next step but the content that you give
me has to be value I and not just a
sales pitch and not just something
written for robots so that's what I
would do basically look at every search
every kind of rank for and then create
content that would be genuinely
interesting for someone who had that
question yeah and definitely to add on
to that too if there are a variety of
search terms that you want to rank for
that's a great place to you know help
brainstorm some blog content as well or
video content you know you can have a
video that addresses one key phrase you
can have a blog that addresses another
so that really helps you know extend the
life for your blog post it gives you new
ideas for your content and which is
actually which is really helpful it Sam
yeah and if you're spending all the time
in making a video you can also turn
those into blog posts I know you guys do
that in a way where you take ideas from
your blog and turn into videos and vice
versa you're spending so much time
creating the energy and investment to
make you one piece of content you can
leverage that in a lot of different ways
you can turn those into tweets that you
send out other facebook pictures or
videos and vice versa if you spent a lot
of time making a video you can take the
transcript and turn it into a blog
article and
take out the Unzen oz and all that stuff
so you'll use your content use it as a
multi-purpose vehicle to help
continually drive more traffic to your
sites
peter is writing in about giving away
information to help him get recognized
in his market as an expert so writing
content giving away things as a way to
get recognized yeah definitely um so in
order to kind of I'm assuming that means
to present yourself as an expert and an
authority figure in that in that topic
so yeah definitely writing content about
that I'm trying to get some guest blog
posts on other companies blogs is
another great way to do that and kind of
widen your audience um in that regard so
you can and you know so you can continue
making connections with other people and
and help get your name out there too
yeah I would also look at if I could use
the media that's another form of content
if I could write a column in a local
newspaper or an industry magazine if I
could be interviewed as an expert on
certain topics when I was first getting
started in my business I would create a
press release every week and send it off
to a list of all the local media and
entrepreneur related media and it was
always a story wasn't the press release
it was a something that they would
actually potentially publish and I
always got at least one pickup from it
well there's a TV spot a radio spot a
newspaper spot magazine article and that
was another great way to establish
yourself as an expert and again you can
then use that content to turn it into a
video of the turn into a blog post in
terms of the tweets so content is really
it's just educating right educating your
customers educating the market and
letting them know that you know what
you're talking about and you should be
the go-to person to connect with when
they need help with whatever topic you
are next video Lauren has a follow-up
question for you Monica who's saying
when you say understand your customers
are we talking about a value proposition
canvas for customer segments or what
tools are you saying to visualize your
customers pains and gains
so basically baking that what do you
mean by understanding your customers so
am i understanding your customers is
that's a great question
you know you know sometimes we take that
for granted because we're in touch with
our customers so often but as far as as
far as what I mean by that is you know
really under getting to know who your
customers are that could involve you
know sending out a survey to even just
ask them exactly what their pains are
and what their needs are you can start
doing this by just you know having a
brainstorm just to kind of see assess
you know who you think your audiences
and you can you know back that up by
sending out that survey and/or putting
up a quiz you can put up a pop-up quiz
on your website to kind of get people to
answer some questions about you know who
they are and what their interests are
what their needs are basically you're
building a persona to help you figure
out who you're talking to
and that's really valuable when it comes
to content because if you don't know who
you're talking to and what their needs
are it can be it can be difficult to
create content for them yeah I see the
two ways of looking at this one you go
data and and you're looking at your
Google Analytics and you're looking at
your Aweber Analytics you see what are
people opening what articles are reading
where people you know spending time on
your website and what tweet gets the
most retweets and what videos gets the
most views you're just looking at
analytics and then you say well people
like this so I'm gonna create more stuff
like this to attract people to me the
other side is heart where you know you
are your own customer and you make
things that make you come alive and
don't care about analytics um the answer
is probably a combination of those right
where you know you're creating stuff
that you're passionate about and then
you use the analytics to support that
and say okay well I want to write about
this should I use top ten reasons to do
this or should I use or why you should
do that or you know how you promote it
and present it you could use the data to
help you I would always start from a
place and this is me because I'm I'm a
passion guy I would always start coming
place of do I like this like what I read
this what I want to share this do I want
to show this to my mom
or my best
there my colleague right and if I don't
it doesn't pass the Epping test then I
don't put it up and we got to redo it
and create something else and so you
looking at the content and making sure
that you love it and makes you come
alive and say yes I would share this
that's a pretty good filter that you
should put up before you release it I
think to the market Kumar is asking is
it is technical knowledge important in
marketing technical knowledge
I think definitely to some extent you
know if if you're in digital marketing
you know you have to have some basic
technical knowledge you know with how to
just operate the computer that you're
using
I'm familiarizing yourself with
WordPress if you have a wordpress blog
or website and you know and there are so
many tools out there that can help you
educate yourself on how to use different
piece of different types of technology
to market your business to which is
really helpful um but as you know as far
as if you're you know doing some
in-person marketing you know there's
different there's different types of
marketing to and but if you want to do
more technical side more digital
marketing then yeah we definitely
recommend having some basic technology
knowledge yeah you know I think it's
getting easier I think it's only getting
easier to be a Content marketer before
WordPress you had to create a website
right and you have to know how to do
that yourself or spend money on somebody
to help you do it now with WordPress
really if you can use word you can use
WordPress it's not super difficult to
figure out and you need to have a
programmer I would just to get a
programmer to help you get it started
and then I would honestly look at what
are you really good at and how can you
maximize those strengths and then
delegate or automate the other stuff so
you know on my youtube channel I my my
best skill is up being in front of the
camera it's not in it's on to being
behind the camera it's not in doing the
editing and the started did everything
myself but as I grew up quickly hired
gotta fill me I hired editors to help me
write a hired researchers so I can spend
more time creating the content and
that's how I went from one video week to
20 videos a week and so really no
understand what you're really good at
and if you are not the tech guy then you
probably will never be the tech guy and
that's okay you can have a basic
understanding of some things and again
it's only getting easier to to be good
at these things
but understand what your strengths are
and go from there you've been using look
at a Weber use I use a weber been use
anywhere but for 10 plus years I'm not
the guy to understand spam filters and
you know all the things that a weber
just takes care of for me templates and
everything right I don't want to have to
worry about coding that I'd never be
able to create that myself if it were me
I would just be doing an email with BCC
everybody in there because I don't have
the tech skills to do it
but there's tools out there like a web
bird that was third cost 19 bucks a
month or something yes yeah $19 a month
to get started I think it's like $1
trial and then nitrate and then $19 a
month right it's it's insane all right
like that's that's an insane use of your
time instead of you trying to figure out
all the time and so I think if you get
the good tools anywhere WordPress or you
build a good team editors videographers
then it allows you to do what you do
best instead of trying to worry about
being the technician all the time and I
think I'll suit you just adding on to
that it's really great advice um you
know everything there's a learning curve
with everything so you know just take
some time and familiarize yourself with
different different tools that can help
you do the things that you want to do
with your marketing and you know just
get comfortable with it there's so many
great resources you can find blog
articles how-to articles to kind of help
you um along the way so that you're not
just kind of flailing around and I
created a Squarespace website not too
long ago and I had no idea what I was
doing um I still don't really know what
I'm doing but you know there's so many
great resources out there it's kind of
show me you know show me the ropes and
you know just every now and then I'll
just go in there just player
with it and you'll you'll keep learning
along the way and you'll find that
you'll you get more comfortable with
different things Jew logo love it simply
say writing in how many social media
venues would you suggest an entrepreneur
engage in especially as companies like
Facebook periscope meerkat blab and so
on make their entry into the markets
it's a great question we hear that one a
lot so I think for social media you know
there's so many great platforms that you
can use but it can get overwhelming
really really fast and I definitely
don't think that entrepreneurs or
anybody should feel obligated to be on
every platform that is in existence
because the it's that's just
unmanageable basically at the end of the
day so just kind of pick one or two to
kind of get started you know Facebook
Twitter Linkedin start with the big ones
YouTube to kind of just get familiar
with you know talking to a social
audience and just getting a sense for
each platform maybe even just getting
started with one or two to really if
you're really just getting started um
and just get more familiar with you know
whether or not that platform is even
right for your business because like
Ivan said you know there are certain
things that you know video might be
better for your business blogging might
be better Twitter might be better it
really might take some time for you to
test out different platforms see what
works see if you're getting the
engagement that you want see if people
are asking the right questions if
they're interacting with you if they're
going back to your website you know
really take some time to sort through
each one and then make a decision at the
end of the day if to see if it's really
right for you I know it can we support
stressful as an entrepreneur because we
have all these things we have to run in
our business already now you know I just
figured out Facebook now we need to know
meerkat and periscope and blab and
snapchat and it can just seem
overwhelming that a new thing opens up
and now you have to learn it I think
marketing 101 is you want to be where
your customers are if your customers are
on this platform in a big number then
that's where you want to be I thought
Twitter was stupid at the start when I
first got onto what people we're talking
about their cats and with a for like
time for this I'm running my business I
don't I don't think that share what I
mean for lunch good for you guys that
it's not for me but I got my name anyway
because you want to make sure nobody
kind of takes your name and squats on it
and does something with it
then I just did a search and I found
that people were talking about me and
talking about my website on Twitter and
I wasn't a part of the conversation
which is not good right like even if
you're not going to be active in the
platform you want to at least recognize
your champions you want to thank them
you want to you know say show some
appreciation them so they're gonna do it
again ongoing because that's that's
gonna encourage them to want to keep
doing it and so step one is figuring out
are my customers here what's the
demographic does it line up with who I'm
trying to sell to and if it does then
you should consider looking at it but
doesn't don't worry about it you know
snapchat skews really young are you
selling to teenagers are you selling to
senior citizens right figure out where
you want to be
I would overlay that with what are you
really good at and where is your passion
right so if you are great on camera like
we talked about or great at writing you
can leverage those talents and those
skills and that passion to create
amazing content so YouTube was my
favorite platform because a lot of
entrepreneurs you guys are all on
YouTube and I love being on camera as
opposed to other forms of writing or
doing interviews and speaking and so
that matches up best for me and I'm on
the other platforms but I'm most engaged
on YouTube and so if you can combine
those things where's your audience and
what are you good at and want to learn
more about where were that intersects
that's we should be
Keshawn is asking Monica what do you
think about the future of marketing the
future of marketing marketing so for the
future of marketing I mean there's so
many possibilities with what can happen
I mean it a lot of it depends on
technology and you know what the
advances of Technology are but I
definitely see a lot of you know
contents definitely a big player in the
marketing game if you're not creating
content chances are your competitors are
and your audience might be searching for
something important and and you know
still going and going to them instead of
going to you so I think the future you
know for content it's definitely you got
a yet you should be producing something
if you're not already as far as
technology goes and what can happen how
it'll help I know a lot of people are
you know trying to find ways to automate
different tasks that they do and I think
that's gonna be a big thing in the
future - I know
Evan touched on that you know if you're
struggling with a certain piece of
technology or if you don't if you just
don't have enough time in the day you
know finding tools that will help
automate some of those tasks can make it
a lot easier so for you know a weber we
have email marketing platforms to help
help you send out emails to your
customers and you know automate them so
that your emails are going out even when
you're busy you know doing other tasks
like balancing checkbooks and you know
other things and you know I think that's
gonna be really important as time goes
on - I think more to add to what
Monica's saying entrepreneurs and
companies are gonna have to become media
companies it's just gonna be a part of
what you do it's gonna be the way to
mark your business it's gonna be way
more effective than taking out ad
dollars that spends you're gonna have to
think about how can I be a media company
and talk about my industry and whoever
gets there first is gonna be the winner
in their markets I think the two other
things I would really look at in terms
of future is authenticity having access
being yourself sharing what really
matters to you instead of just being a
corporate boring CEO like why does
somebody buy from an entrepreneur it's
because they like your story they like
your passion like what you're trying to
do otherwise they just go to the big
company right and so that's your
opportunities to be really authentic
tell me your story tell me why you
started tell me why this mean so much to
you why you get fired up about this and
I'm gonna like your stuff better than
everybody else I'm gonna want to come by
your stuff because I feel connected to
you even though you've never met me but
I am connected to your story and then I
see a lot more live stuff happening to
stuff like this spontaneous things that
are that are showing up or planned
events where you get tired
to connect with people at the business
doing the things that just now what a
rover is doing right being able to
connect with people at their company and
learn from them and get knowledge from
them I think is where a lot of companies
are going to be going and the companies
to do that first and show their love for
the community say hey we love
entrepreneurs let's put this series
together I think the companies to do
that first they're gonna win
Ricky's writing in hey just wanted to
see if this will be recorded as well as
the replay yes this will be this will be
a video on my channel that you can watch
forever we're in discussions about maybe
doing little clips as well and putting
them potential on a Webber's channel
we'll see but yes every time we do a
live hangout is also recorded so it
lives forever you guys can come back and
watch the replays Sharon is writing in
while we're we're bumping up against the
clock already time flies I find there's
so much information out there and so
many companies doing what looks like the
same thing how do I decide which theme
is the right one for me
I work as a holistic practitioner so
coming up with a marketing theme I mean
how do you do this the advice you give
to entrepreneurs if you have a holistic
practitioner we starting the newsletters
and doesn't want their news that I look
like every other holistic practitioner
what would you what advice would you
give them yeah I think that kind of goes
along with you know a lot of the things
that we've been saying you know just
kind of finding what you're what you're
specifically passionate about as far as
being a practitioner goes a holistic
practitioner goes if there's like one
angle that you can take that is so
unique to you you know why did you get
started with doing what you're doing and
really just kind of emphasizing that and
having that theme kind of leap through
the content you create and again you
know really just identifying what your
potential customers you know might not
know about as far as that goes and
educating them on on different areas of
that world and I used to work for a
content marketing agency and we had a
couple of healthcare health-related
clients and you know there's definitely
a lot of overlap there
um but you know each one kind of had a
different angle they had different
topics that they wanted to talk about
which helped them you know stand out in
that space a lot of hospitals for
example you know they have salt Centers
for excellence and so that's kind of
their focus and their expertise and
that's bigger medical world and so you
know we were creating content for them
that spoke to those areas of expertise
that they wanted to be known for so I
definitely say you know think about what
you know as Evan that has been saying
before think about what is is your you
know your purpose your brand's purpose
and like the value that you bring to
your audience to your clients and figure
out how you can incorporate that into
your into your content is gonna be key I
love it
I think the add-on that I would try to
find what makes you uniquely you by
combining some of your passions together
so as an example a buddy of mine loved
hockey and he loved being a financial
advisor those are his two biggest
passions he could sit in front of Sports
Center and watch the same hockey replay
20 times and never get bored of it which
of his wife nuts and he loved being a
financial advisor the challenges
financial advisors there's tons of them
right there's more financial advisors
and there are holistic practitioners is
tons of them and so the way he stood out
was he combined his love for financial
advising with his love for hockey and he
became the financial advisor for hockey
players and so now when he's talking to
hockey players
so he's wears a lot of the NHL guys and
they love him because he loves hockey
like he gets them he's one of them and
so it's not easy for another financial
advisor to go in and try to take
business away from him because they
don't love hockey like he does and so
that's uniquely him and so I look at as
a holistic practitioner that may be one
thing that you love you're really
excited about you're really good at can
you bring in one or two other things
into that mix that then make you stand
out as a holistic practitioner for max
for cancer patients for children for you
know whatever it is drug recovery you
know like if you have a meaningful story
and this is
and that's really important to you I
think you'll start to realize that you
could be super unique in that market
compared to everybody else chill TV
music is a musician and is trying to
build up as YouTube audience you have
recommendations for youtubers who are
trying to be musicians for youtubers who
are trying to be musicians definitely
showcase your talent and you know if you
can you know really start building your
audience on there by just showing them
what you're all about and you know
depending on what your skills are what
your expertise is you know really you
can really play that up on YouTube and
if you're a musician maybe if you want
to educate other people on how to you
know sing better or how to play an
instrument you can also share some
educational videos as well in addition
to you know just videos of you you know
doing your thing and I would also
encourage you to add an email signup
form to your to the end of your videos
to kind of encourage people to sign up
to your list keep coming back for more
content and really just build your
audience that way yeah I love it I mean
to add to that I would say as a musician
I would try to do cooperative videos
find out the musicians I don't know what
you play if you play the guitar find
someone who's a singer I find someone's
a drummer and just do different collab
video so you can promote each other to
your audiences and I'd also do a lot of
cover songs if I was starting off as a
musician on YouTube I would have my own
stuff but I would also put my own spin
on songs you know you turn a Frank
Sinatra song into something new and and
modern or your own beat to it or I don't
know again what style you're doing but
put your own twist on things and that'll
help get you a lot of attention and
people then will want to come and check
out music and I totally agree with the
getting people onto your list because
with YouTube most people don't turn on
email notifications so you're just
hoping that they're on YouTube when they
find your video where when you send them
an email people check their email every
day right so if you can get somebody on
your list I may not be logged into
YouTube that day but you can send them a
link your video and the more likely to
watch
maybe time let's see how let's see how
fast we can go here share is that some
question and and sharing also wanna
throw the answer so two people wanted to
know about how to start a blog so how do
you start a blog that's a great question
so I think before you even you know sign
up for a site like Squarespace or
WordPress and get into the technical
aspect of building your blog I
definitely recommend you know just
taking some time to think about your
expertise thinking about your brand but
you stand for you know a lot of these
answers you'll you're hearing often
right now because you know they're just
common themes that apply in so many
different scenarios and really just
knowing who you are is just so important
and marketing yourself because if you
don't know who you are then it's going
to be you know kind of confusing to
write content about things that are
gonna help your your audience so um yeah
and identifying your audience is also
really important to making sure that you
understand what their needs are
um that's going to be really crucial and
so how kind of help do that you know we
also we often recommend you know just
taking some time to sit down and think
about frequently asked questions that
people ask you about you know anything
that's related to your industry your
products your services whatever your
your brand is about and just our
drafting content the most important
thing too for blogging is just getting
into the habit of writing and you know
creating continuous content and you know
it can take some time for people
especially if you're starting out with
writing for the first time it can be
really challenging and frustrating um
but you know once you're if you're aware
of that and you just keep pushing
through it your writing will get better
over time
and you know you can share your content
with other people and get feedback from
feedback on it before you even start
building your blog but once you start
you know having some content to work
with I definitely recommend building um
you know a collection of blogs that you
can just start posting automatically
once your once your blog is ready to go
and you have a website up and then you
can just you know post something once a
week and just kind of see how it just
get a sense for how it does and gauge
its performance
check analytics on Google to see you
know how many views you're getting share
it on and make sure you're sharing it on
social sharing it through email and just
you know really taking your time with it
it's gonna be key yeah if I was setting
up just some of the technical things I
would definitely use WordPress we talked
about it before it's the easiest system
to use you need a programmer to help you
set it up but from then you can if you
can use word you can use WordPress I
would pick a theme you can you can buy a
themes for cheap 50 200 bucks or you can
just get a free theme and they can get
it installed so you can find something
that looks like you know what you want
and I would say get your email set up
get your get your newsletter signup set
up from the start I think one of the
biggest things that entrepreneurs say is
I wish I had started building my list
earlier and so I would do it right from
the start I know we're talking a lot
about email marketing today but you
can't talk about content marketing about
email so yeah right away I would start
with with building my list and integrate
my free bonus or whatever it is into the
blog so I start getting newsletter
subscribers right away and I think in
addition to that you know definitely
create an editorial calendar that's at
least has a content ideas for two to
three months out you know this is a
great way to help you prepare the
content that you're gonna create this
way it's not Monday morning and you wake
up and you're like oh I need a blog post
today and you have to scramble to find
an idea that can get really overwhelming
um but if you have an editorial calendar
where you have a list of content ideas
you know based on things that you know
your audience is interested in you know
things things that are trending in the
in your industry right now that's a
really great way to keep you organized
and it also gives you an opportunity to
create content in advance so you know if
you know you're going on vacation at the
end of the month you can start working
on your content earlier set it up in
WordPress and you'll be ready to go so I
definitely definitely recommend creating
an editorial calendar very cool
so it's insane it's been an hour already
I can't believe it there's still tons of
questions coming in but I know we got
but up so Monica first of all thank you
so much your time really appreciate
again lots of great comments coming in
thanking you for people who want to
reach out to you can they can they hit
you on Twitter can they find you
somewhere what's the best way to get in
touch sure yeah you can send me a tweet
on twitter my handle is at mis Montesa
mi SS mo NT ESA I'll pop it in the
comment section too but it's been great
thanks for having me I love talking
about content and I'm excited to see
what everybody does with their advice
today awesome well thank you for
spending at a time I will add that
Twitter handle too in the description
and for those of you who aren't watching
it live you can leave a comment below
let us know what you think and will be
involved in the discussion Monica again
thank you so much thank you guys for
watching to believe and it'll see you
soon